knight has been offside the whole game  on the edge of the board not helping its  army and that knight is going to drop as  well later on prague still hasn't played  four games in this uh tournament he  won't he's until tomorrow  yeah it's  i mean do you think like prague because  he's young he has more energy than the  other players i mean some of the older  players i mean no one's that old in this  tournament um  it's it might help a little bit um  saving energy by playing only three  games a day yeah yeah it must be because  you're playing one less game so uh yeah  everything helps at this level i guess  so and also you know the fact that he's  been victorious even in those  very bad situations means that he also  he's had great night sleep you know here  wow it's three points four pragnando  winning again another match win for  prague in only three games he is taking  the lead now in the oslo esports cup  after a dominant performer